que l'on en vient l'arrestation en
algérie de karim tabbou foule une des
figures de l ac
une interpellation qui intervient 48
heures avant les législatives anticipées
que la mobilisation populaire n'approuve
pas également arrêtés isaev qu'adil
journaliste et directeur du média radio
m
alors qu'il sortait de son un bureau à g
il est accusé entre autres à de
diffusion de fausses informations à même
de porter atteinte à l'unité nationale
le point tout de suite avec est notre
envoyé spécial à j'ai passé mme siby les
algériens appelés aux urnes samedi pour
élire leurs députés pour ces élections
législatives anticipées rejetée par le
irak et l'opposition qui demandent un
changement radical du système politique
en place depuis l'indépendance du pays
c'était en 1962 malgré la démission du
président abdelaziz bouteflika en avril
2019 et l'élection du nouveau président
à delma djité bouillant décembre 2019
les manifestations n'ont pas faibli dans
l'ensemble du pays
là des enjeux principaux de ces
élections législatives sera de faire
revenir les algériens dans les bureaux
de vote et éviter le scénario des
présidentielles de décembre 2019 et
celui du référendum sur la constitution
en novembre 2020 qui avait connu des
records d'abstention avec 60 et 76 % de
non votants deux échecs pour le pouvoir
qui reste plus que déterminé à
poursuivre sa feuille de route
électoralistes quitte à ignorer les
revendications de la rue l'opposition
elle est fermement décidé à boycotter
ces élections comme une partie des
algériens alors que le pays s'apprête à
tenir ces élections législatives
l'opposant algérien karim tabbou figure
centrale du l'irak est le directeur
d'une station de radio proche de ce
mouvement pro démocratie ont été arrêtés
jeudi selon leur entourage